Tom and I have been friends and work
together before for quite a while we
know each other originally from the
costume designers guild awards which
we've produced for the last 13 years and
tom is a costume designer he's actually
the costume designer on Saturday Night
Live for the last 20 years so that
second actually just terrific work there
absolutely and Tom was it I mean I guess
being so immersed in the world of SNL
was this always a thought that maybe
this would make for a great documentary
or was it something that you needed a
person who's not in that world to come
out and tell you yeah I think it's a
little bit of both we were having lunch
one day and talking about the things
that had been going on about the 40th
anniversary and that sort of stuff and I
think it had been germinating in my mind
for a little bit and since I had been
there for 20 years and you begin to
think why am I still here what what is
what's what's drawing me here while I am
I staying here and sort of a cat coming
back to this idea of what is this until
about what is this know about there's
such a bigger context of that and then
through the course of having lunch you
know really working on just the colonel
um you know what this idea was from an
anthropological standpoint and then jail
and I by the end of the lunch sort of
had flushed it out and started running
with it now you guys cannot be the first
people who have approached Lorne
Michaels with what this kind of an idea
so I wonder what was it that how did
that how did that go down and what was
it that made him say yes to you where I
would guess fairly safely that he said
no to a lot of other people I think our
favorite thing is that he said no to
Bill O'Reilly yeah that was our little
inside joke that was our little shout
out to that situation by including bill
on the dock Tom and I went in together
to pitch it to Lauren and I think it was
a combination of two really important
things that were different than some of
the folks that have come to him in the
past timing super essential he was ready
and open to the idea because it was the
40th anniversary so we sort of tied it
to that and Tom so it's the 2 t's timing
and tom tom has a relationship with them
that's pretty fundamental and
and there's a significant amount of
trust so myself and the rest of our
producing team several of whom are here
we benefited from Tom and we're all wind
a grave Tom and Tom would I mean it
really wouldn't have been possible in
even a fraction of the way that it
turned out without that kind of
cooperation right because you guys seems
like you got unprecedented access to
people and places even just the opening
shot where we see the camera move is
incredible who's ever seen that for you
before right it I do have to say I mean
you know all of the people involved in
the film have done an amazing job so i
just opened the door and they ran with
it you know part of my job was to sort
of steer them clear of certain land
mines that might be happening while we
were shooting them that sort of stuff is
so go over there don't go over there
move over there but you know we had an
amazing crew who was like they really
knew when to push in and when to pull
away and really they I say the director
and some talk about those guys were like
little ninjas who running around and
never really getting in anybody's way
and half of them didn't even know we
were ever shooting the film you know
when at the end of it they were like
wait you guys were even hear what was
going on and that was sort of what we
really wanted for them to have no idea
what was even going on now with I think
82 minutes you had to obviously make a
lot of decisions about what goes in what
goes out and I found it interesting that
the attention is less on the creation or
the way that the show works than it is
on the role of the show in society and
sort of the way a show comes together
and I guess if was that always the
intention from the start or how did that
how'd you guys well first of all thank
you for framing the question that way I
wish I could take you I Oliver odd
because you nailed it that's exactly it
it's truly that was I think a
fundamental thing that that that
inspired both Tom and I I think it's
fair to say at the very beginning was
that we wanted to do something totally
different and we wanted to really
elevate the show and a lot of ways and
show that it's while it is indeed a
sketch comedy show and it's it's
hilarious
it's a lot more than a sketch comedy
show and it's become this interesting
barometer in which we can sort of
measure what's happening in our country
at any given time it's this little time
capsule and that notion is what really
appealed to us is that there's been
amazing retrospectives done on saturday
night live for many years there's decade
after decade ken Bowser did a phenomenal
job with those there's an incredible
book there's you know there's just
tremendous materials about the making of
the show and we didn't want to do that
it's been done and it's been done well
so as a sort of respect for those that
came before us we wanted to do something
with a completely fresh perspective I
think while we talked about some
difficult issues it was still respectful
so it was done in a way that you know
again it wasn't about the show per se
and the controversy that surrounded the
show rather it's significant
controversies and issues that are facing
our country in which the show reflected
and I mean certainly if we're talking
about racial diversity it's a very it's
a pretty timely issue in our country and
it's just reflected on the show and I
think it was important to us that we
show you know that it never was you know
it was it was one way this era and now
it's a different way this era it's like
well from 1975 all the rights to 2015
racial diversity has been and is
currently an issue so that's that's the
same with our country and with Saturday
Night Live and I think right you know
all of the topics that you brought up so
I don't think it's in any way sort of an
attack on the show rather it's just
acknowledging a you know a dialogue
that's been there for a long time yeah
now to come back to this bill o'reilly
point that you brought up earlier there
were some people that obviously expect
you're gonna see tina fey or somebody in
this but I giuliani or O'Reilly or some
of these other folks that they appear
would not be obvious choices to somebody
and so I just wonder how you decided who
wasn't and wasn't going to be included
in terms of the talking head portions
yeah I mean I think again it's
definitely a collection of all of our
filmmaking team we had a phenomenal
filmmaking team so we have really strong
producers and a talented director and we
all sat in a room and said you know
let's look at sort of key pivotal
moments in history through this 40-year
window and look at when did we feel as a
collective team that those sort of
historical accent ameri
were reflected on Saturday Night Live so
it wasn't what's the funniest sketch or
what's the most popular you know actor
it was you know what actually resonated
and I think so Giuliana you bring up as
an example you know 911 was obviously a
pivotal moment in our country and how a
comedic show responds to a tragedy like
that is is quite telling and is an
important sort of you know pin point in
history so Giuliani was an integral part
of that and therefore it made sense to
have him and I think for Bill O'Reilly
it was you know a lot of people perceive
it as a liberal show it's entertainment
you know it's a comedy show and we felt
like it was important to have a
conservative voice and and of course
there was the additional benefit of the
fact that he was declined to do the
document or said entertained us but one
question I had for you tom is that
having been there for so long did doing
this examination of the show teach you
anything that you didn't already know
about the way that it it operates or had
you know came to be or anything else
anything that you really learned through
it um no I mean certainly one of the
things I learned you know the whole
creation in the 70s and how the show and
that the germination of how the show
really began and all that sort so and
when asking Lauren some of those
questions some of those questions were
more about well what do I want to know
from him um you know I've read a lot of
stuff about the show that sort of seven
I've spoken to him a lot about the show
but a lot of that was like well you know
what what did I want to know when we
were trying to come up with the
questions now do you think that you
start til you do touch upon the role of
SNL in today's size versus 1975 and I
guess what I wonder what your
conclusions are having really looked at
it under the microscope here is it
what's the state of SNL going forward do
you feel that it can be as culturally
important and relevant in a world in
which there are now instead of three
channels like in 1975 now hundreds
you've got to compete with the internet
which although they have sort of
embraced the way of using that
smartphone all of this is it what's
what's the future look like for them I
mean that's definitely a silver you know
sort of a crystal ball type of question
I I think one of the things that we've
talked about a lot since making the film
is that Saturday Night Live one of the
things that differentiates it from sort
of all of the other programs out there
and makes it such a unique entity is
that it has this really interesting
balance of paying complete and total
respect and credence to its history and
its legacy in its tradition the
structure remains the same the cold open
remains the same you know this history
and branding of the show remains intact
while at the same time every single week
it completely represents what's
happening in the country at that moment
in that current event sort of window
right so it changes with the times but
at the same time stays the same and I
think that's the magic of it and we
addressed a little bit in the
documentary itself about the changing
media landscape and how Saturday Night
Live has changed to accommodate that you
know Andy Samberg spoke at length about
that and I think it just speaks so
strongly of the show that's still today
it is quite you know it is you know in
the sort of forefront it is a
water-cooler show I don't know how many
of you have had this but still to this
day I say if I see something political
happen or I see something pop culture
happen to go I can't wait to see what
they do about this on Saturday and so
that's kind of been ingrained in us and
its generational so while there is
indeed so many more places to get your
content and there's platforms changing
it's really the core as we all know in
the filmmaking community it's the core
of the content that's important and as
long as they keep the let you know
bringing that I think that I think it'll
find its voice so that's our perception
at least you know what I'm having yeah